widespread floating trains nuclear
fusion Marty McFly's hoverboard
it sounds like the future but many
scientists say these types of advances
aren't as far away as we think they all
hinge on one thing a room temperature
ambient pressure superconductor and in
July some scientists claimed to have
found just that sending stock prices for
companies with a perceived connection to
superconductors Soaring a breakthrough
like this really could mean longer
lasting batteries for our devices
revolutionizing Medical Imaging it could
mean more efficient electrical grids it
could mean improved high-speed trains
there's almost no aspect of our daily
life that a room temperature ambient
pressure superconductor wouldn't touch
if commercially applied that's why
investors despite doubts surrounding the
search are still backing the effort
here's where the science stands and what
it could take to bring such a
superconductor to Market
when electricity flows from one place to
another it travels along some type of
conductor usually a metal
those conductors put up some resistance
which results in some of the energy
being lost as heat that's why your phone
or computer can get really warm
superconductors eliminate that
resistance and can transmit energy
without loss
superconductors obviously if they
conduct electric current perfectly it
means they're extremely efficient but
these materials typically only work in
extreme conditions temperatures as cold
as roughly negative 320 degrees
Fahrenheit or extremely high pressure
there's always an investment to do the
necessary cryogenics if you're using
copper and it has a little bit of loss
but the superconductor is much more
expensive you know for most of your
application you might want to use a
copper instead just because you have a
superconductor the question is whether
it's going to be useful or not because
of that superconductors as they exist
today are used in limited circumstances
for example MRI machines but there's
also been investment in broader uses the
Departments of energy and Homeland
Security have funded initiatives to
create more resilient power grids using
superconducting cables like one in
Chicago that uses liquid nitrogen to
keep cables cool ultimately the reason
why people are so interested in this
space terms of investment
especially unlocking a room temperature
and pressure superconductor again would
revolutionize Medical Imaging it would
make it so that magnetically levitating
trains were more accessible cheaper to
build more efficient it would make it so
that our electrical grids truly would
become revolutionized because
superconductors potentially promise huge
advances in technology finding one that
can work at room temperature and ambient
pressure has become a holy grail for
scientists and investors a group led by
scientists at the University of
Rochester claimed to make a major
breakthrough in March a superconductor
made of rare earth material combined
with nitrogen and hydrogen that they
said worked at roughly room temperature
the study was peer reviewed but the lead
researcher has come under scrutiny the
University of rochester-led group did
not respond to request for comment then
two other papers released in July
detailed a potential superconductor
called LK 99 that combined copper lead
phosphorus and oxygen and worked at room
temperature and ambient pressure videos
of the substance floating above a magnet
a homework of superconductivity
circulated online but those papers
written by researchers who mostly worked
for the privately held Quantum Energy
Research Center haven't yet been peer
reviewed and many scientists say LK 99
is just a magnet rather than a
superconducting material many groups had
difficulty replicating the experiment
the quantum Energy Research Center
didn't respond to requests for comment
still the enthusiasm for the July
research triggered big stock swings for
companies like tsunam Mobis and American
superconductor before a room temperature
ambient pressure superconductor can be
brought to Market it needs to be
replicated regularly in Trials that's
what Norman's group at Argonne National
Laboratory is trying to do now with LK
99 it's going to sort of take a while to
sort out what was actually going on
there it opens up the space right
there's lots and lots of minerals out
there very few that have been studying
from a physics perspective maybe there
are other surprises out there waiting
for us replicating results can take
weeks or months if even possible in its
production needs to be scaled up which
can take much longer
it's one thing having little microscopic
samples in your laboratory is another
thing to to make kilometer you know long
wires we just don't know until you know
what the material is and how easy it is
to make and then it's like how you know
can you can you wrap it and make a wire
out of it until you know those things is
is really hard uh to to figure out what
kind of lag will be from Discovery to
Applications the superconductor cable
system used for the power grid in
Chicago took years and approximately 19
million dollars to implement any
Discovery or invention or change in the
field is ultimately net positive so
there's it's almost like a nothing to
lose everything to gain scenario it's
not like they have spent decades
researching this trying new recipes and
it has yielded no results so it's
perhaps just a matter of time
[Music]
foreign